ça me rappelle le sketch de cyprien quoi
tu te souviens son sketch là où il joue
et le président hu est le mec s'en bat
les couilles et tu m'écoutes a déjà pris
la grosse tête c'est pas le moment mais
ça va bien se passer
des stress des stress mec je vous ai 1%
responsable je suis pas censé être là en
fait j'en devais représenter des idéaux
des reproches sauter une classe non
politique
vous représentez internet ne pas se
faire élire tous genres là d'un moment à
l'autre
je dors des des coups de fils de chefs
d'état du monde entier
j'ai fait un discours j'ai plus de vie
privée mon propre peuple va me détester
pendant cinq ans des stress mais je
m'attendais pas non plus à ce que tu
sois élu es bon tu as tu fait campagne
pour ça depuis 2010 est de souvenirs des
musclée à chaque fois dans les
commentaires cyrus président et toi même
sur ses tablettes
tu disais ça tout le temps mais je
pensais pas avoir autant d'influencé
ouais je pensais pas non plus que
retrait d' influence mais enfin regardes
tu as eu des mecs comme jérôme jarre qui
ont réussi à réunir des millions d'euros
en quelques jours
c'est fou mais tu vois c'est pas le seul
du tueur en plus qu'ils vendent impact
sur la société
tu te souviens quand squeeze a annoncé
qu'ils donnaient les terriens boom
pénurie de tofu c'est fou et franchement
des fois je me dis qu'on a de la chance
parce que ça pourrait tomber sur
d'autres personnes là pour le moment on
serait toujours bien sorti
ça peut être hyper dangereux si
l'influencé ou et ça c'est grâce aux
gens aussi tu vois c'est les gens qui
décident qui met sur le devant de la
scène soit à l'horizon une sorte de
responsabilité par rapport à ça et
franchement parce que ça sonne bien
falloir faire confiance confiance tu te
rappelles quand même que tu as fini face
à ce tir et la numéro second tour ils
t'attendent ouais c'est parce que en
fait on l'a entendu à la différence mais
n'importe quoi là
j'ai pas envie ouais mec tu peux pas les
lâcher comme ça à temps aux on y est là
ça y est ce que tu voulais tout là tu
peux enfin renverser le système mettre
un bon coup de pied dedans comme les
extrêmes et alors on va peut-être qu'ils
ont raison j'en retiens c'est le moment
enfin tu es le premier à le dire que les
inégalités se creusent que peut-être
qu'on se fait entuber depuis le début
non oui ok mais tu vois genre le système
tout n'est pas à jeter quoi on peut
l'améliorer on est obligé de le détruire
et le balaie d'un revers de main regarde
souvent bacon a fait une révolution
après on a eu un truc totalitaire alors
j'ai pas regardé les virées adhérents
ayant même la france avec napoléon nos
libertés elles sont fragiles mais les
libertés fondamentales
ça c'est du solide ouais alors
techniquement ça peut quand même assez
vite je pars genre imagine juste le fn
passe derrière ta 2,3 débordements dans
les cités derrière pour les fachos juste
après l'élection c'est un peu open bar
pour la violence le gouvernement peut en
profiter
ils font passer une loi martiale c'est
dix fois pire que l'état d'urgence
derrière ils font ce qu'ils veulent on
arrive je t'admire peur j'ai tellement
de doutes eh ben c'est normal de douter
rien que les gens intelligents qui
doutent déjà gelé des soins m et bah si
tu les situent les déçoit c'est pas
grave voilà non mais c'est vrai je sais
pas enfin tout le monde te qui j'ai bien
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie en fait j'ai
quand je voyais des meetings il y avait
de la lueur dans les yeux des il se
disait ça y est c'est le renouveau c'est
lui je suis tellement content que ça
soit on se connaît depuis qu'on est
grosse sérieux qu'est ce tu veux qu'il
arrive je parie qu'ils changent d'avis
tu vois qui se met à me détester c'est
un peut arriver je dirai la vérité ça
peut arriver mais ça va pas arriver au
moment où tu vas dire mes chers
compatriotes
[Musique]
mais chut je vais vous dire ce avec de
la chantilly sur le visage mais je
trouve plus les vidéos
donc bon on va le faire comme ça
j'espère cette vidéo vous a plu c'était
un gros délire
voilà ça m'a fait marrer d'imaginer ça
merci à mes potes qui ont rendu ce
délire possible donc
thibault à nice tom et alex merci à vous
merci à vous les gens d'avoir regardé
j'espère que ça vous aura plu et si vous
a plu si ça vous a plu pardon n'hésitez
pas à ne pas vous abonner parce que je
ne fais jamais ce genre de vidéos donc
si vous abonner pour ça vous serez
forcément déçu on se revoit la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo
enfin j'espère si tu vois bien et d'ici
là bas prenez soin de vous bisous